hey guys I'm Jessica watching gamespot
news and to help fight those monday
blues let's talk about video games first
up that room of the pokemon is on its
way to nintendo switch appears to be
holding a lot more water today a new job
advertisement translated by Siliconera
and IGN has revealed that pokemon
developer Game Freak is hiring people to
work on a quote globally popular RPG
that will be developed for console the
job calls for a candidate who has
experience in creating character models
on the level of wii u and PS vita of
course just our luck the title of the
game isn't stated but it's described as
an RPG that is popular on a global scale
that just about anyone knows so make
your best guess Game Freak is best known
for developing the main line pokemon
games they also created smaller titles
including Harmon ight and timber the
badass elephant next up dance favorite
overwatch character is undergoing some
major changes I'm more of a mercy girl
myself lucio the Brazilian healer with a
penchant for dance music and
rollerblading is getting quite the
overhaul on the public test realm the
area of effect of his healing and speed
boost ability crossfade has been reduced
from 30 meters to 10 but the amount of
health restored has been increased by
50% lucio sound barrier ultimate that
Awards a personal shield to him and his
teammates has also had its range reduced
from 30 metres to 20 Blizzard have
implemented a visual indicator of the
new ability ranges to make it easier for
you to adjust to the changes on the buff
front the projectile speed of the sonic
amplifier has been increased and wool
rating now provides a movement speed
boost jumping off a wall will also
provide an additional speed boost as
always these updates may not make it
into the live game in this form if you
want to check them out for yourself you
can access the public test realm via the
pc version of overwatch finally Mass
Effect Andromeda has received a PC patch
ahead of its release tomorrow and before
you ask it does not address those
animation issues according to producer
Fernando me lo the patch for bioware
latest
I epic will address problems with sound
in multiplayer a conflict with the
course a utility engine which produces
black screens and FK is not working in
multiplayer server side fixes are also
on the way to resolve a problem where
certain challenges could not be
completed be sure to check out our
Andromeda review if you haven't already
as well as our two-part mini doco on the
story of Mass Effect Andromeda that's
everything I got for you today do let me
know what you cared about in that
comment box hit that subscribe button if
you liked today's video so you don't
miss any of the gaming news and I will
see you again tomorrow